when do you wear your Stanley Cup rings
well one I wear all the time Dan
especially when I'm going out with you
because usually you have some gravitas
but one of them I can't wear because
it's just a little too ostentatious but
that being said I proudly have it in my
whole what do you remember about that
that feeling the first time touching the
cup it's 35 pounds but when you grab it
initially you're like whoops and then
all of a sudden it's like a feather and
just you think I the first thing I
thought I believe it or not where all my
youth hockey coaches that either
supported me or say you have no chance
of a clinic in it so that's that's the
fruit is the first thing I really have
to picking a cup up you think about all
the people that helped you along on the
journey the first time around the second
time around you just appreciate the
entire moment you're there and you take
it all in it's not nearly as emotional I
think the second time especially when
you do it back-to-back it's a little bit
different we were talking about
legalized sports gambling there's a new
push by a representative a Democrat from
New Jersey that they're going to try to
get this on president Trump's desk
during his term to get legalized
gambling what would legalize gambling do
for the sport of hockey I don't know I
really don't know I don't I don't follow
it down I mean obviously I'm a huge
football fan and I'm not afraid to make
a wager in football but I don't know
about the hockey part but I really don't
I wish I could tell you more about it I
know one thing and I know you've been so
bullish on the national market
I think we're developing more and more
big-time hockey markets in
non-traditional cities then and I think
a big reason why is because of the
players that we have and we really
haven't had a bad draft in our league
since 1999 that's a long time so our
league is chock-full of players right
now that I couldn't tell you back when I
was coaching that we had nearly as many
good players we have now in the league
well the only reason why I bring up
gambling with hockey is that's you know
now people who might not be as
interested can bet on you know they love
to bet on things and I wonder with a
hockey team in Vegas is it just a matter
of time before we just see legalized
sports gambling not just me
no hockey with everybody it's a great
point I don't know but I think it's a
very very fair point in something that
will require some time to break it down
the storyline of the playoffs so far has
been what or who I would say the
Nashville Predators have been a
phenomenal story is an eight heat and
what they've been able to do to get to
the Stanley Cup final and their
marketplace tan has been phenomenal I
can't say enough good things about the
national storyline but I think the
biggest thing in this playoff has been
besides the marketplace has been the
elevation of star players you know
you're seeing it with the defenseman in
Nashville you're seeing it here with
Sidney Crosby Evgeni Malkin you're
seeing with Erik Carlsson and Ottawa you
saw with Ryan Getzlaf obviously with
Anaheim I think the elevation of star
players in our plant has been phenomenal
explain the explosion in Nashville it's
it's an overnight sensation after 20
years we've built the team that's built
to last their fundamental principles and
building the team was so strong then
getting defense and building around
elite gold training has always been the
Forte of David Paul their general
manager you can see it it's come to
fruition they're the only team I think
still left in the playoffs that could
overcome the loss of their top two
centers and still win playoff games and
a big reason why they manufacture most
of their offense from their great
defense whether it's Ryan Ellis
romagnolo CPK Subban the tss home it's
been phenomenal to watch and I think
really Dan when you look at a Peter
Laviolette won the Stanley Cup coming
out of the lockout in 2005 with Carolina
he was the first coach to really embrace
open ice tactics with the red line out
and more of an emphasis on offense and
you could see that almost translate
itself to national worries the current
head coach and the way they play they
play and they push from the back end
with their defense generating a lot of
their offense
he's Pierre Maguire NHL NBC inside the
glass analyst winner-take-all game seven
tonight you can see it on NBC and CIN at
8:00 Eastern Penguins hosting the
Senators could Sidney Crosby be
underrated Pierre
I think he's underrated I think Sydney's
never played as well as he is right now
I think people in the league that
actually have to make their living
coaching against them or playing against
them really appreciate where Sidney
Crosby staking his game tree right now
is awareness and faceoff situations is
awareness in terms of transition defense
his down low coverage his ability to
elevate really support wingers that
maybe aren't first-line players it's
been phenomenal watches developers a
player I go back to when he was a high
school player Chaddock st. Mary's in
Faribault Minnesota watch him and then
watch him be the youngest player to ever
score for Canada a world junior in
Helsinki Finland when he was 16 so I've
seen the concepts aggression in his game
the biggest thing to me though then the
way he's led it's not too he always led
by example because of his abilities and
his hard work Abbott Dan he's leading by
example on the bench just the way he
vocalizes things with his teammates the
way he respects the officials he's
really matured into an amazing leader
Wayne Gretzky talks about this openly
where he said you know if he played
nowadays he would have a hard time
getting four of 50 goals in a season
that Crosby has a whole lot more talent
than he does so how do you rank players
we love to do this with other sports
we're doing that now with LeBron and
Jordan can you compare Sidney Crosby to
Wayne Gretzky no two totally different
players I think Wayne had amazing
peripheral vision probably as good or
better than any player that ever played
in the game and I include Bob you are
not who I think is probably the best
player that ever played but Muriel had a
certain style to his game and an ability
because of his size you know Mary's
almost five inches taller than Wayne so
Mario's ability to dominate players with
his size and his underrated speed was
phenomenal Sydney's a combination of all
these great players but is sheer
strength on the puck reminds me so much
of the great Peter Forsberg inning there
in Sydney when you watch him there's a
combination of forsberg Lemieux Gretzky
and probably because of his bat cam
skills Bryan Trottier so you put all
those players together and that's what
you have in Sidney Crosby that's how
great this kid is he really is
yeah it's a shame that mario lemieux was
not able to play up to his full
potential because of illness injuries
but you know having cancer i I think
Lemieux could have been the most
dominating offensive player of all time
had he stayed healthy well dan you're so
right on if you were to ask Wayne that
question he would probably agree with
you Wayne and Mario played together in
the 87 Canada Cup and there's so many if
you get a chance to go on YouTube and
look at some of the plays they made
together just unbelievable hockey plays
against a phenomenal team from the
Soviet Union at that point with a
potpourri of amazing players from Russia
and not by the Soviet Union but I would
tell you this I had the privilege of
working with Mariel for two years and
he's done things in hockey that I've
never seen another player do he's almost
like LeBron in the sense of how big he
was being that skilled and playing you
know on the offensive end
I don't know it just he was he was a
unicorn I think if they're not many guys
that size Ovechkin is I guess similar in
size maybe
is that a fair comparison as far as just
size and athleticism with Mary loom yes
yeah and they're both right-hand shots
the biggest difference though Mario's
ability to dominate the puck in traffic
I haven't seen another player like that
in my time in league you know going back
this is 29 years in pro hockey for me
and I haven't seen another player with
his size is skill and ability to
dominate the pocket specially in
confined areas as Mario Lemieux have fun
tonight there Pierre Dan it is great
talking to you and I know you've been on
the Predators train I hope you will find
the time to come down in music city for
the Stanley Cup final it would be a
pleasure and a privilege to take you
inside the glass for the warm up Dan and
then to take you after the game to a
little place called legends can I Drive
the Zamboni with the dentist I would
have to check with the people in
Nashville but Dan I'm telling you if you
went there you would be blown away but
what they've created down in Nashville
it's a phenomenal place to watch a game
I appreciate the invitation Pierre I
might take you up on that and have fun
tonight tell the boys we said hello
I will bet oh thanks so much for having
me out I really
appreciated Pierre Maguire NHL on NBC
inside the glass analyst the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience